vendredi soir il est 20 heures et les
bénévoles de la croix rouge de saint
quentin en yvelines charge le camion
pour effectuer une maraude jusqu'à
minuit on peut répondre par rapport à
une aide vestimentaire alimentaire accès
aux soins à travers comment tout ce qui
est soins soins dentaires dentifrice
brosse à dents par exemple et autres
besoins demandé par la personne
rencontrée
l'action sociale de la croix rouge
française de saint quentin en yvelines
englobe 31 bénévoles ce soir cinq sont
présents donc eleana catherine luc
dominique la roselyne ils viennent en
renfort du samusocial 78 de novembre à
mars
parmi eux il y as n'a fait des maraudes
depuis quatre ans elle est devenue chef
d'equipe il y a deux ans et demi ça
m'apporte la satisfaction de la
satisfaction dans la mesure où honnête
de les gens et quand on voit le travail
des personnes qui sont volontaires et
que et qui sans qu'ils arrivent à s'en
sortir mais malgré tout ça fait vraiment
ça fait du bien durant ces opérations
des liens se créent entre bénéficiaires
et bénévoles
nous avons nos habitués qu'ils sont dans
le secteur près de chez nous donc
notamment georges que
qui est un sdf depuis 17 ans dans la rue
donc on sait ce qui leur fait plaisir de
manger donc en lui par exemple jean chez
le chocolat au lait donc on ne sort
jamais sans chocolat au lait à chaque
maraude
il y ana est en contact avec la
régulation pour connaître les
différentes missions de la soirée en
cette période de grand froid l'unité
locale met en oeuvre des dispositifs
spécifiques pour des personnes vivant
dans la rue vers les hébergements
d'urgence compte par l'hôpital mignot
ont service des urgences
ce cas de personnes qui nous attendait à
tous les coups il va falloir les amener
à satory dans le temps au chu ce soir
après avoir récupéré les deux
bénéficiaires aux urgences de l'hôpital
andré mignot du chesnay rocancourt
les bénévoles de la croix rouge les
emmène au chu le centre d'hébergement
d'urgence de satory à versailles
on va bientôt s'occuper de vous laver
d'un rien mais c'est ok bon signe je te
laisse on va voir georges et puis je
t'appelle quand on le quitte ok bon
d'érection montigné les bénévoles se
rendent disponibles et sont au plus près
des personnes rencontrées vivent dans la
rue à l'image de george à la rue depuis
17 ans les bénévoles de l'unité locale
de la croix rouge vont toujours lui
rendre visite
alors quand on fait une soue à la grande
halle est les bénévoles répondent aux
besoins fondamentaux des personnes
rencontrées chocolat plus amis des
compotes web le web comme georges 124
personnes sont suivies à l'échelle de
l'agglomération
bonojean
[Musique]